[Music]
everything that happened in the second
world war in all these
historical periods and in others also for
us is very relevant and very
important to recreate and there is also an
idea that remembering all the
mistakes that could be made there is some
opportunity that  in the future let's not
fall into the same thing again
[Music]
[Applause]
the world
hollywood my name will be on the
story about six years ago
and finally I am the
unit's lieutenant in charge long since they are in charge
many times of revising  the team having
to review people many times
also has to coordinate maneuvers such
as what you can claim
historical accuracy is very important
above all because we are not recreating
situations that someone who is
veterans experienced because out of respect for them
we have to do it well
or  It was
the two caps
to organize a recreation, the normal thing
is first to choose a historical moment
or a battle an activity  life that we want to
recreate, then we look for a location
that is consistent with that and we define which
uniforms are the ones that correspond
to get the uniforms. I think it
is an odyssey in a country like Chile,
most of them have to be manufactured or
imported from everywhere
where we find the necessary pieces
and well there are many things that can
be rescued in this case but
mainly between an edge that
we can rescue the theme of the story
constitutes the battle
many times one knows them but when
living them properly one knows
much more  direct from the
emotionally good character also makes you put on
your shoes probably the
person had to go through that
[Music]